hey screw you
excuse me that is no way to address the
superior Oh what was that all about
you forgot her birthday it was yesterday
my man you do it okay I insist basically
after Phil's blackmailed Angela Michael
asked them both to step down from the
party planning committee because there
was too much drama
what he said was easy there was a
problem with having one head of the
party planning committee she becomes too
powerful so he pointed to heads party
planner I'm okay literally the stupidest
humiliating that's on my side so this is
fun my birthday was yesterday and
everybody forgot I got really dressed up
and excited and no one said a word there
wasn't even a party I think sometimes
people are really mean to the hot
popular girl are you kidding I'm not
done yet
great this fits in the palm of my hand
you haven't blown them up enough why
have you chosen brown and gray balloons
they match the carpet what is that it is
your birthday Pierce Damon a fact not
even an exclamation point this is more
professional it's not like she
discovered a cure for cancer I can't
believe I have added this looks are you
trying to hurt my feelings because if so
you are succeeding
unfortunately my feelings regenerated
twice the speed of a normal Lance okay
good then have you collected the money
from everyone I am working on it how
much do you have so you sell ours that's
how much you and I contributed damn it
Jim I said I was working on
what did you do what did you do did you
learn and yeah I bet you learned things
huh like how to fashion a shiv hey what
the hell's going on why don't you tell
Jim where you were from ages 14 to 15 I
was taken up in juvie what juvie Nile
detention center where they send
teenagers yep
very good what did you do huh huh hey
Dwight sounds like she was 14 so maybe
we want to go a little you know she's
old enough to get married she's old
enough to follow the law
what did you do my boyfriend not me so I
stole his boat I mean he told me goes
his boat is actually his father's and I
just thought it'd be really romantic
like Thelma and Louise but with like a
boat and it was the worst year of my
life and I can't believe that you guys
are making me talk about this on my
birthday I thought you said yesterday
was your birthday you know what I got
you a cake dad I want to see the cake
and tada I hate it how do you hate it
it's a cake well there's no flowers or
toys or I mean there's nothing on it
where did you even find a cake like this
I mean doesn't have my name on it do you
guys know what my name is my name is
Kelly right I forgot if there was an E
between the L and the Y I just told oh
no I mean I don't even know what the
theme is what's the theme he's Bert's
fasting those are fans there's always
the theme it's always a theme nice job
on the cable bozo okay know what next
time I'll let you get the cake and I get
to scream at the birthday girl okay so
all we need is a theme and cups and ice
and punch okay Izzy hey what's that show
that she's always talking about oh my
god it's just how you are with Pam cuz
she must want to shoot herself in the
face you know what I could use a little
help you know what I'm a little busy
we a lot to do and you are putting up a
very effeminate sign is that what you've
been doing it's nice eminent it's
festive you've been making that sign for
something that we could just announce to
the whole office hey everybody the party
is now at 3:00 oh no I just read it on
the Sun we have to write my suggestions
down to I'm not writing horse hunt I
don't even know that means it's in the
name okay
so far our ideal party consists of beer
fights to the death cupcakes
blood pudding blood touch football
mating charades and yes or something
you're right I forget horse hunting it's
stupid is there a birthday that you
remember that you loved here's one
it was dark warm wet a sudden burst of
light an intense pressure like I'd never
felt before father dressed in white
pulls me forward
mother bites the cord they stop forever
stop that story that's disgusting and it
doesn't count so give me another one
shrewd stones celebrate birthdays idiot
it started as a depression-era
practicality and then moved on to an
awesome tradition that I look forward to
every year what about you actually when
I was seven my dad took me in a Natural
History Museum New York and we looked at
fossils all day and at the end of the
day he got me a little plastic
Triceratops it was awesome
that's cool hey you know what's even
cooler than Triceratops every other
dinosaur that ever exists did fins
enamel
happy birthday it's not a surprise this
doesn't look good what you have a cake
you have a delicious cake with your name
spelled correctly told you you havin her
a theme though you don't hear a theme
you see it why is there a chicken on my
cake that's the best part that
represents a pillow or a television our
theme if you will because the fun part
is you get to decide on an hour of
television or an hour of napping that's
our theme oh yeah I love it oh yes okay
good so what's it gonna be Kapoor can
she pick a half hour of each no oh then
pick TV take a nap no no no watching TV
at work is really cool big nap nothing
good is all right now
Bonnie honey's on you know I have been
watching TV all week I choose now all
right okay nap it is everyone out get
out we're gonna be eating cake at our
desks let's go move it let's go Coco
Coco come on em this is for you and
happy birthday tell thank you okay
you've got one hour ticks it asleep
hmm great cake Thanks
birthday time is over now go make up for
all the work you missed when you were
taking your nap many happy returns
you